so he's got a runner basically he's got
a dude outside the house at all times
just sitting in his car
24 hours a day it's a personal doordash
so if he ever needed something i don't
know if you noticed he was like oh i
want to play settlers of katan so he's
like hey can you go get katan and the
guy would just run to the store go get
katan and bring it back within 50. what
he was outside our house the whole time
and he's outside the studio wherever he
goes
these two people are there 12-hour shift
seats so 24 hours a day
he's got somebody just
watching us back
[Music]
all right so
i guess we we're all gonna we all want
to talk about the same thing right yeah
this is gonna be
the camp mfm recap episode i'm pretty
sure that's all we're gonna talk about
because it was kind of amazing and i got
a lot of things to say i have a lot of
things to say let me set the background
because you're the one who organized it
so i think you need a third party here
so basically a month ago
sean said i'm going to organize a
basketball weekend
and i want you to come and i'm going to
invite some other people please venmo me
and show up at this address at this time
that's pretty much all i knew about i
didn't know anything else and i think it
was three weeks in advance right yeah
something like that three four weeks in
advance and in between then it got sort
of canceled and put back on again
because i didn't know that first i
couldn't get anybody to come uh i
invited five people the f of the first
five people only one said yes and i was
like yeah maybe maybe maybe this idea is
only good in my head and ben not
producer ben business partner ben pushed
it through he was like
nah i think we could do it and then we
ended up with like 27 people there and
oftentimes when i'm saying shawn is
doing x y and z in reality i mean ben so
ben was it seemed like was really the
backbone here you maybe had the idea i
don't know who had the idea but ben levy
was the guy and he did a really good job
so basically three weeks out it just
says hey
come to north carolina
uh
in raleigh but near duke and we're gonna
have a basketball camp and just show up
that's all i knew and then i get an
email i booked my flight i sent you 1800
i uh
i i
a day before you send out who's coming
and it was like me and you both ben's
uh a couple hubspot people like jonathan
and then it was like hasan minha hassan
minhaj it was mr beast and it was like
20 other really amazing entrepreneurs
and you rented out this
shoot i don't know like uh basically a
farm like a binary yeah yeah with like a
lake and a zip line going into the lake
and it was like 24 entrepreneurs and you
hired this amazing basketball trainer
who was also an entrepreneur so he like
fit in and was really insightful and we
uh
you had like
you kind of half-assed the incredibly
unimportant things like there was like
when we went and played basketball i was
like hey is there any food here and
you're like well there's just a bunch of
boxes of clif bars
like okay that's okay i'm okay with half
ass on that thing so anyway we all
stayed in these two airbnbs and just
played like board games and like acted
like 12 year olds for uh like two nights
and it was amazing it was so cool
yeah it was basically a summer camp for
grown-ups
and um the origin of it is pretty simple
like i like i love meeting new people i
should say i actually genuinely love
meeting new people in fact the podcast
was originally started as a excuse to
just get to talk to really fascinating
interesting people
but i hate most of the traditional ways
to do it i don't like going to
conferences i don't like going to
networking events i hate just being like
hey you want to grab coffee
um so so i basically was like look
there's a bunch of people who i think
are dope
i would love to hang out with them get
to know them
you know
strangers become friends friends become
lovers that's that whole thing and then
finally i was like what if i just did it
instead of a networking event or a
conference like what if we just did it
with something that
uh it would be dope no matter who came
and so we were this idea for a
basketball getaway and we're like all
right here's the criteria they love
basketball number two they're a great
hang and number which is just great to
hang out with and number three
that they can teach us something because
they're a baller in their own craft
whatever that craft is and so that's why
we had people in the house that had
built billion dollar companies we had
people who bootstrapped their way into
you know tens of millions and that's
where they were we had people that were
entertainers like mr beast or husson who
had millions and millions of fans and
we're creative talents we had people
that used to be in the nsa we had a
bunch of people from different
backgrounds come up and uh and join this
thing so that was the criteria and
that's basically how it played out and
i'm pretty sure by the way that it was
the best weekend of ben's life
like ben i don't know if you're married
or ben wilson i don't know if you got
married over the weekend but
i wanted to talk about this
i want to talk about ben in the middle
or the end but i have a feeling i told
ben before we recorded i go ben the next
six months in your life are i think are
gonna have the most change you've ever
experienced in your life
totally agree totally agree with that in
fact i was gonna text you something very
very similar which is like i don't know
if you realize this yet but your life is
about to change because you can't really
go through um
you can't just be surrounded by wildly
ambitious people
who like and believe in you
and
uh spend time you know seeing other
people who have realized their dream
come true
and not go back to your house and look
at yourself a little differently in the
mirror like you're gonna look at
yourself and be like all right let's
turn that ambition knob up two notches
right let's ha let's turn that faith and
belief in myself up because i saw that
these people are no smarter better than
me they're just people like me there's
they just went for it dude
all those quote smarter quote better
quote more successful people were
looking up to ben
did you notice that
yeah well there was just a feeling of i
wouldn't even say looking up necessarily
it's more like equals i think everybody
everybody there viewed themselves as an
equal to everybody else i'm sure
everybody there had a moment where they
were like dude i'm way out of place some
people are like the basketball they're
like oh you know i i play basketball but
i'm not really like that into basketball
so some people maybe fell out of place
there a little bit some people felt out
of place in the house because they
didn't know anybody they saw everybody
else you know half the people knew the
other half but but some people knew
nobody coming in and half the people and
some people i bet fell out of place
because they said wow i'm talking to
this guy who's you know
leaps and bounds further ahead in their
business career but everybody had to
deal with that and then come to terms
with that i think that's you know part
of it's part of the part of the
challenge so say your piece ben and then
i actually want to come back to you and
then me and sean
sean i want to go like you go i go you
go i go of like the things that we
learned this weekend because i know that
you have a list and i have a list
yeah great so ben do a quick one first
uh there's just so much to say it was
one of the best weekends of my life it
was so amazing
sean i just i guess i would ask there's
like a really special feeling that is
very difficult to convey uh throughout
the entire weekend you guys touched on
it a little bit of just
like no egos even though people were at
very different places like there was
just this really feeling of
openness and connection and like even
though there were these really really
successful people in all these different
domains like very little dick swinging
like everyone just uh on the same level
learning from each other it was very
cool sean like what do you think it was
that went into this weekend that created
that environment where people were able
to like feel that way and be that way
with each other
i think it's three things you actually
mentioned two of them
first was the weekend felt very special
and i think that when you when people
feel like they're a part of something
bigger than themselves when people
have a little bit of awe or intrigue or
curiosity or fear even
they get out of there out of their
comfort zone and so part of it was if
you make something that that feels
special that feels different that
inspires them all or some they they
don't know what's coming next
it brings everybody back to sort of like
an equal footing of the sort of a
childlike thing i remember when
uh so we invited alex basil who's a
trainer to to a bunch of nba stars like
kyrie irving and trey young and this
guy's like you know he's like
the top of his craft he trains like he
came from training like you know kevin
durant to us he sent us a clip he's like
here's what i was doing today tomorrow
i'll be seeing you schmucks and like
right like you know but that first five
minutes i would say when he had us
doing very simple like drills everybody
was spread throughout this whole private
gym that we had rented and we're all
literally dribbling the ball almost
accidentally in unison like that old
nike commercial where all the the beats
sync up
there was little pockets little moments
like that where it just felt special and
um
you know so i think that's the first
piece is you gotta give people a feeling
that they're part of something bigger
than themselves number two
um
you invite people who are inherently
curious so everybody there i would say
actually has an ego everybody there has
an ego otherwise they wouldn't get to
where they were but bigger than their
ego is their curiosity and so as long as
you can create the curiosity factor
where who's this person oh they're
interesting oh they're interesting
they're interesting then again the
attention go they're so used to
attention being on them they're so used
to being the most interesting person in
the room so you want people who are
naturally curious about the people
around them so even the sort of quote
celebrities or kind of the big hitters
that we had in the house that were maybe
the the wealthiest or the most popular
people that were there
i picked specifically people that in my
limited interaction with them
they were very curious like for example
um when you had first met mr peace you
met him before we did you were like yeah
he just called me and he was like yeah
i'm on this walk i do this every night i
just call somebody and say yo teach me
something
and i said already i know everything i
need to know about this person same
thing when hussein came on the the
podcast he asked me more questions that
i asked him i felt bad afterwards like
dude i just blew the podcast because he
was asking me questions i'm supposed to
ask him nobody gives a [__] about me
they wanted to know from him but that
showed me like he would fit into this
group because he would be curious about
oh what's this real estate guy doing
what's this guy doing who's rolling up
like those claw machines at amusement
parks and pinball machines and like
that's what this guy does and he's
building a little mini empire doing that
right you need somebody who's curious
otherwise they'd just be like that's
weird i don't know stay away from me
right you're different okay what's the
third i would say the third was the
immersion so
it wasn't like you couldn't get away for
better or worse like
normally you go to a dinner you sit
there for three hours it's sort of a
safe space you know the routine and then
you leave and you get to go back to your
place so you can you can stay surface
level with a lot of people with this
it's like dude i'm sleeping in the same
room as somebody else sometimes i'm
definitely under one roof for the house
we're eating breakfast together lunch
together dinner together we're figuring
out logistics uh you want to shower
first or me so you get people out i
shared a room with two other guys yeah
exactly so like ben shared a bed
yeah
ben had one of our crashers so i think
he had to you you invited him so you had
to deal with that
yeah that's right
uh but i think that's the other thing is
so immersive that there's nowhere to run
and at some point you're gonna just be
your real self because you can only fake
the funk for so long you can do it for
two hours three hours four hours by hour
five
you're just gonna be sitting there you
know
tired and cranky and you're gonna be
your real self and like that's just the
way it was so i think that those are the
three things i would say that like
created that environment well and i was
gonna say it started from the top down i
mean i would i would say mostly it was
your brand partially it was the brand
you and i have created together which is
actually similar to both our
personalities but basically like you're
a casual person
you're a relatively low eagle person as
in like you're easy to be around and it
kind of stemmed from from from that
so i think that actually matters a lot
um and it was like the house we were in
was kind of like gross but in a cool way
like people on my twitter were like dude
that's a sick set you made it look like
a grandmother's house i'm like oh no
that's just like this woman's uh bedroom
it just looked like that um all right
can we get into like some of the stuff i
i've got one do you want to go first i
i've got one for density all right so
first
all right so for the if you're under 35
and you maybe don't know who mr b says
he's a youtuber who's only 24 maybe he's
got 100 million subscribers really big
business that makes nine figures a year
and he just makes tons of videos that
gets viewed by
a lot of the world so
i have an interesting story about him so
we were in a car and i was talking about
like a popular band or politics or
something i think we were even talking
about a movie like harry potter and i
could tell
that he didn't he wasn't registering
what we were talking about he was trying
to partake in the conversation and be
polite but i could tell that he didn't
he didn't like know what i was saying
and i said something to him i go hey
have you ever heard about this thing and
i think it was like harry potter or
something or it was like something like
mainstream and he goes no i really i
just don't know anything about that i've
never seen that and i could tell that he
didn't know this about a lot of things
and i said what's going on how do you
not know about this and he goes when i
was young i made a goal when i was 15
when i was young 15 i made a goal to be
the most popular youtuber in the world
and i pretty much stopped paying
attention to everything else so if
whatever you're talking about is not
part of like youtube culture i don't
know what it is
and that was incredibly interesting to
me and he said a few other things that
showed his intensity the second thing
was um he said um i've gotten so big and
i've like studied and gotten great at my
craft that i can't really learn too much
from other youtubers so i talked to a
lot of experts on human behavior and
researchers in order to improve my craft
and also i don't really have work weeks
so i just kind of work and i get
obsessed over stuff and i roll out of
bed at 10 or 8 a.m or whenever it is and
my team like tells me what i have to do
and then i just work all night until i
get tired and i go to bed and i work
seven days a week and then occasionally
i get burnt out and i take a couple days
or however long i need to recharge and
then i do it again i don't pay attention
to
the normal work week the third thing
that he did was he didn't care about
rules so sean and i did a podcast with
him at about a it ended at like 11 p.m
and hassan made a joke like going to
play ball and uh jamie was like uh mr
beast's real name is jimmy he goes um
yeah let's go right now and as he said
that his two co-workers that were with
him started getting on the phone calling
high schools principals of schools like
all these people in order to get a
basketball court and we couldn't we
couldn't make it happen but he was like
really really uh going after that to
make that happen and i thought that was
crazy interesting and once someone said
something to him someone said something
like well what if they like don't let us
for insurance reason he goes well just
tell him i'll give him a million dollars
if someone gets hurt
and it was just so funny that he went he
goes that usually does the trick yeah i
was like how many times have you done
this bro
he just didn't pay attention to rules i
thought that was interesting now i'm
gonna con uh contrast that with this uh
other person i'm not gonna say his name
but you know who i am who i'm talking
about he was a young guy in his 30s he
might have been the wealthiest person
there and he wholly owned a business
that was worth probably 500 to 800
million dollars and it made tens of
millions
a year in profit and he basically told
me that he worked really hard to get it
going but now he works one week a month
one week and then the other week a month
he likes to travel and then the other
two weeks of the month he's just kind of
searching so his company he owns a bunch
of companies the other two weeks he's
just online searching for other deals
and companies to buy but at a fairly
casual pace and i thought this was
interesting because these two guys were
the exact opposite of when you met them
one guy you'd be like oh you're easy to
be around you're well balanced the other
guy jimmy not well balanced at all
but both of them had this laser focused
intensity of when they're on they're on
and they played uh their game at a
really really high uh highly levered so
lots of leverage uh
and that type of scale where it was just
like anytime if i make a decision the
outcome is potentially big and i don't
always have to make a lot of decisions
i agree with everything you just said
and in fact i think we could probably do
a two episode series literally just on
mr beast because
um and i don't mean that because i'm a
fan like in fact i
i i watched i watched him after
i like yeah i've watched a couple of his
videos it's not like i went in being
like ooh this guy's my favorite you know
like it's not that right like i watched
a couple's videos it's like oh okay i
get it that's cool i get why that works
but like you know whatever it's kind of
a dumb uh you know kind of a dumb video
thing but it's like you know it appeals
to people it's good good it's good good
fun and um so it's not that but i am now
a much bigger fan of him after seeing
how he operates i'm gonna tell you a
couple stories so you didn't go for this
but a couple of us who arrived the day
before uh ben was there
we got to go visit his studios and we
got to go tour his production facility
which is like i don't know ben how big
is that place like 50 000 square feet or
something like that like basically an
airplane hangar right
imagine a giant airplane hangar and on
one end they're like oh we're building
this set over here it's like a hollywood
production thing so there's four
production teams
like individually that are each creating
different videos at the same time
because they're all going to get
released you know next month or whatever
and you're like in rural north carolina
people make this pilgrimage out to go
see warren buffett and they call him the
oracle of omaha
and i was like man we're we're driving
we're making this pilgrimage we're
driving two hours after we we flew
six hours to get there yeah but i was
like where are we and where are we going
for this pilgrimage and i was like and
so we get out there but it's like had
that same thing very special you go
there and it's like
this group of people who are all
singularly focused on one mission which
was to create the best videos possible
to create the best videos that get the
biggest reactions that you know like and
that's all they were all doing 24 7 they
were all just working on that so i'm
gonna tell you a couple of kind of
amazing stories from that
so we go
first of all we get into one of his
videos so in one of his videos like
they're filming the grand finale when
the person you know either wins or loses
the money and uh so we're like in that
video now uh as just like random
bystanders but the second thing was we
were like so what is your um
like what's your model dude and his
model is basically this
he
started off making videos with no money
just him in his bedroom doing
dumb stuff like i'm gonna say logan
paul's name 100 000 times i'm going to
take this plastic knife and i'm going to
cut through i'm going to saw through
this plastic table in the next 48 hours
he just sat there taking a jagged you
know picnic like
you know plastic knife and trying to cut
through the table he would just do stuff
like that no budget no whatever but he
knew he understood even at that time
like
okay what would get somebody's attention
what would make them laugh what would
make them watch what's a bit of a
spectacle low budget spectacles now he's
doing high budget spectacles like we get
there there's a camera flying above us
there's fireworks and smoke bombs and
there's crazy stuff going on right
because now he's investing i think on
average ben what is it like
half a million or a million dollars
i think i said 1.5 1.5 yeah 1.5 million
dollars per video just on the production
that's kind of insane and so
um the thing i admired the most about
him was
okay in that house there was let's say
25 all everybody there was
entrepreneurial so if i said who here
is entrepreneurial how many out of let's
just pretend that 100 how many people
would raise their hand
almost all
okay hundred we were at 100 100. i said
who here has a clear vision of what they
want now how many people do you think
are raising their hand
okay maybe i say
who here can think about that vision and
can honestly say that it is
wildly ambitious like mr b's ambition is
to be you know a billionaire youtube
creator to get to a billion followers
make billions of dollars he has told me
that he wants to be one of the richest
men on the planet the most famous person
on the planet and president so okay
that's his ambition what's yours right
so um how many could just say in their
own right that i'm thinking really big
i'm thinking wildly ambitious we're at
sixty percent where are we at now maybe
twenty
down
we're down to twenty percent and now if
i ask the last question the most
important question of them all i said
who here
is truly and totally obsessed meaning
you are willing to give every hour of
your day every dollar you create you're
willing to reinvest back into your thing
you don't take anything off the table
you don't hedge you know buy that nice
house you know buy those fancy cars you
know put it away for for your kids you
you wake up you do your thing till you
pass out and you are getting every hour
every dollar and every ounce of your
soul right to that ambition how many
peoples are left how many what percent
are left raising their hand how many
people
he might be the only one and i would say
well it's also because he was the
youngest
but
that could just you know it could play
out where even if he's not the youngest
he still would have behaved that way
he would be the only one and that's not
just about that house i could go down
into san francisco i could say hey
gather around every venture-backed
founder here i could go into uh every i
can go to a a gymnasium full of people
who all say they want to be a big
youtuber or all say they want to be a
comedian by the way
this isn't necessarily a good thing it
could be a good thing it could also i
think be his downfall
i think it's an incredible thing i don't
necessarily mean it's a healthy thing
but i think it it was honestly just kind
of stunning
oh yeah like it was absolutely stunning
i agree with you but i but i'm saying it
it could go either way it could be uh
you know the strength could become the
weakness
there's a reason most people don't do it
i think is what you're saying which is
like there's a price that comes with
that and that price is a price that most
of us will not pay what do you think ben
i just think there's a couple things he
said throughout the weekend that i was
like oh this guy's so successful but
to sam's point like he's on a nice edge
if you play out his life a hundred times
i think in like 25 or 30 of them he
literally ends up on the street as just
like an addict because he does have that
obsessive personality and if he had
ended up for whatever reason obsessed
with not the right thing that's the way
it would have gone i also think that if
he if he if we had a list of like i have
a list of like three things that might
be his downfall keep in mind the guy is
like 24 so he's gonna evolve quickly
but one he was incredibly naive about
business which is actually a pro i think
in a lot of cases but in his case um i
think that like you have to get a little
bit less now you even learn a little bit
more about business you know the thing
you said about him cutting through a
table with a plastic knife that's kind
of how he's done his life he's just like
you know what i mean like he's just like
brute force his way and i think that's
great that can get you a long way but in
order to last and be as big as he wants
to be like a bezos you gotta have a
little bit more sophistication as you
grow he's got plenty of time though the
second thing is hiring i think that um
he kind of told stories that it made me
seem it made it seem like he just hired
his friends and it's like hey
you're fun you want to do this
uh that i don't think that's going to
cut it either and then the third thing
is company building we asked him on the
pod about uh like work hours and about
like meetings and it
uh he i actually don't remember if he
did it i don't think he did a great job
of answering it but the vibe that i got
was it was like a little bit like just
whatever jimmy wants jimmy gets and i
think that's okay for a little while but
in order to be as big as he wants to be
you've got to have a little bit more
company building a little more process
oriented things like that that are kind
of the antithesis of like being a cool
youtuber in many regards
so i'll disagree with you on a couple of
those i think that
um
first of all i think he's 24 so i
remember when i was 24 24 i became a ceo
for the first time of like a real
company a company that had revenue and
uh employees that were not like my two
best friends from college
and
where he's at at 24 and where i was at
24 is like if me and usain bolt go and
run a race it's like there were there is
such a
like on one hand he's sitting in a room
i think the you know the oldest person
in our group was maybe 43 and you know i
would say average age is maybe like 34
35 something like that uh probably
something like that by the way i'm not
insulting him i'm incredibly impressed
right so i just think where he's at on
the learning curve like yeah there is no
shortcut to the learning curve you've
got to learn all these lessons but where
he's at is actually pretty far along and
the brute force approach actually works
like you said there is a strength to
that and i and i think that
if you're just what he's if you're doing
what he's doing which is you're just
like
f it i'm doing it i'm holding nothing
back i'm gonna go all in
and i'm gonna repeatedly go all in until
this like just i just find a way to make
this work um
i think that overcomes a lot of the
like mistakes you're gonna make right
maybe for the first maybe for the first
billion or two
yeah yeah exactly i i think that that is
a great attitude and what he proved is
that you could have that attitude for
like late stage in in your career even
though he's 24 like he's got late stage
in terms of results even though he's
probably in 10 100 in most cases he's
late he's late stage but um in order to
get as big as he wants he said he wanted
to build multiple
uh 10 billion even i think he said 100
billion company you know that's we're
talking walmart you know like you you
you can't always bet the farm at that
size and i'm gonna be honest with you i
had an initial reaction to him that was
sort of like
there was a part of me that was like ah
[__] this guy right and not because he
did anything bad he's totally nice but
there was something that was like his
ambition is almost uncomfortable to
where
you're like i'm not talking to somebody
who's who they don't live in the same
reality that i live in
um and so my initial reaction was like
okay you're saying things that don't
either they don't make sense or it's
like too like one-sided or it's like
just like
pure unadulterated like raw ambition
and there's something uncomfortable
about that because i kind of like people
that are like like one of the things i
admire is people who are well balanced
so i told him this when i was talking to
him i was like
he was basically like i admire elon
steve jobs jeff bezos like these are the
people that i admire i'm like them i'm
wired like them and i like to hang out
with people like them and i go
yeah i'm not like them
and we're on the phone and now there's
like
you know like a 10 second uncomfortable
silence because it was true i was like
what am i going to do pretend i am no
i i could just you know i'm going to say
what's real and i was like you know i
was like that doesn't mean i'm not
ambitious i just point my ambition at a
different outcome
so those guys
those guys all created like
world-changing
like they were they became the
wealthiest men on earth they um created
like you know world-changing like
spectacles like landing rockets on you
know self-landing rockets self-driving
cars electric cars all this crazy stuff
right uh created the iphone so those
people they were wildly interested in
that way there are other people that are
widely ambitious in other ways i said
you know like somebody i look up to i
modeled myself after is like naval i
think he's really successful in business
but also
he's revered because of his wisdom not
because he created the iphone right like
you know he hasn't gone through five
marriages and breakups and like you know
he hasn't like been bankrupt and then
back to the top and then is depressed
but he's super successful he's like to
me that's not winning but i get it for
other people there is winning i'm glad
there's people who think that's winning
because they're the ones who are gonna
create the next iphone and create the
next tesla but i just was explaining
that to him and i think that that was
the only i don't actually think he's
naive about business i don't actually
think about anything i just think like
when you when you have your play style
it's very sexy to be like
my play style is the play style my play
style is the one is the cool one and all
the other ones are weak for these other
reasons and i think as people get older
they really start to respect other
people's play styles i think this has
happened for most of people i i really
get along with where they're like
it's like yeah they can admire a
billionaire as much as they can admire a
single mother because they're like dude
these are just different games but i
really adm i i can right right i could
admire and not in like a token just
saying the right thing kind of way like
they truly feel it in their heart like
um like you know like they truly feel
that wow what you're doing is your super
bowl and i respect the way you approach
your super bowl and your super bowl is
just as valid as my super bowl
that's a great way to put it the way
that i also put it is i say i don't care
about money i care about people who like
actualize their dreams and their dream
could be to be the best parent the dream
could be to be a billionaire it could be
to be an athlete to be strong to be
skinny i don't care what exactly your
dream is i just want to see you achieve
it and that makes me happy when i see
someone going places and it just so
happens that money and traditional
success is a very practical way to
measure that or to like achieve it like
it just says like well i just do this
business thing as opposed to being the
best parent it's a little bit more
challenging but yeah i i completely
agree with you
we have another friend or i have a
friend
you met him i don't know if you don't
know if you love the guy or hate the guy
because he also is uncomfortably
ambitious remember he came to a dinner
with us i don't want to say his name but
uh he came to a dinner with us once and
you could describe your impression of
him but he he's also embarrassed to be
around him
i met him when he was 1920 something
like that and he
at that time was basically like yeah i'm
like i'm going to be a billionaire
multi-billionaire uh just a matter of
like you know is it at 25 or 26 27 but i
don't know when
and um
i was like so do you date he's like no
i'm just gonna wait till i'm a
billionaire that i'm gonna date like you
know the hottest woman on earth who's
also like you know
uh loves me and is like the heir to the
throne somewhere right like he just he's
like i'm just going for a 12. and he's
like um you know so first time we have a
multi-billionaire then i'm gonna date
this 12 and marry her
and then i'm gonna have like all these
children and then my children are gonna
do this and like
and i was just like wow that's like you
know
and like if somebody else was like
really excited about their thing that's
like kind of small he'd be like well
that's kind of a waste of time right
like you could just why not just do
something bigger that would make you
more money and like he's just so
matter-of-fact so black-and-white about
it how's he doing is he in a way that's
not
rude like he's not trying to be rude but
he just genuinely only obsesses over his
thing which is in his case like
investing and being like a better
investor than warren buffett he's like
you know i've i've watched every video
read every book by warren buffett ray
dalio all the greatest investors i've
studied them i'm just as good as them
yeah i mean i'm younger than them but
i'm just as good at them in fact i think
i'll be better than them uh you know by
the time i'm they're they're 90. i'll be
back how's it going
i mean who knows i don't know i can only
i literally can only check in with him
so often because
if you talk to him too much it's just
like oh dude like i get i get a headache
like hey i feel insecure because i'm not
as ambitious and then b i just get
frustrated because i'm like dude come
back to reality um like you're floating
away in your own bubble somewhere but i
like people like that those people also
are like they serve a real place in my
life
can i can we can we can i bring up a
different topic other than mr beast
really quick that was
subtle but
crazy fascinating
um so ben levy invited this guy whose
twitter handle is commodore
and commodore is famous i guess because
he
started a dow and he's trying to buy an
nba team and he's raised tens of
millions of dollars to do it
and i started talking to this guy and we
started talking about uh you know just
all types of stuff and i go what's your
name by the way and he goes commodore i
go oh that's a sick name like why'd your
parents name you commodore
will i forget what it was but he goes oh
that's not my real name um i'm i'm
anonymous this weekend i go what he goes
yeah so like in order to get rid of in
order not to have like some legal
implications as and i don't actually
know what all the implications were he
goes i'm just anonymous and i go does
anyone here know who you are he goes no
no one here knows my real name um ben
levy the guy who invited me he has no
idea who i am or my name and i was like
what that's interesting so i just called
him commodore and we talked about like
family we talked about his wife and
children where he lived and how like you
know i am maybe familiar with that area
we talked about all these things and we
got like 30 minutes to do a really deep
conversation i was like what would you
do what were you doing before this he
was like oh i was doing this this and
this i was like uh oh wow that's amazing
what was it called he goes oh i can't
tell you i'll dox myself and i was like
oh and i got back and i like remembered
we are anonymous and i thought that was
so fascinating what did you think about
that
i i don't know i didn't find it that
fast but now that you say it i'm like
yeah that was kind of crazy like it
didn't feel crazy
it didn't feel crazy you people who have
their you see people who have their like
handle online and that's their persona
but you're right i've never actually
just met one of those people in real
life and have them just be like yeah
that's just that's my identity i've just
given like i don't use my my birth
identity my my legal identity i use my
online identity as my main identity
i called them commodore the whole time i
thought that was his real date for the
first 24 hours every time he walked over
people like ah commodore hey where's
commodore is he ready to go and it's
like
that's not like who is this guy nobody
here knows who this guy is and we're all
okay with it that was kind of right that
was kind of amazing and i was like can i
just take a picture of you and like
reverse search this he goes you can
but you won't i was like you're right
i'm not going to but yeah
there was sort of a respect at some
points like i'm not going to try to know
this because you're cool and i don't
need to why why would i do something you
don't you're not comfortable with you
don't want that all right i'm i'm your
friend i'm not going to do that to you
dude that was it was so weird at first
and then it became completely normal and
now i know i totally get this a
non-thing and i asked him i go do your
friends know who you are and he's no
he's like they a lot of them that just
don't know what i do for work
so there was a group of people there
that are pretty interesting so one guy
who we both loved who we did a pod with
so i guess i'll explain the rest of the
setup so um
we did a couple other cool things i
thought we had a chef who's there at the
house just making all the meals that was
great so nobody had to think about
anything
we had um just cutting food the whole
time we just had like trays of fruit and
like snacks the whole time that was
great yeah yeah it was incredible and
then we had um
kevin durant basically sent to us like
30 pairs of his shoe dude everybody
who got there they got
a pair of his shoes we got a custom like
shirt jersey that said camp mfm with
your name on the back of your number so
people kind of had they're like jersey
for the weekend
um
we got like they also sent like nike
sent bags for us uh so there's a couple
things that were like cool you know why
i was talking about the moments in
between the moments we tried to have
some moments in between the moments it
felt like christmas morning like with
all these shoes here and we all like got
there and like unwrapped them it was
really cool
yeah we all turned into little kids like
unboxing our thing and be like oh yeah i
got it like you know all these people
could afford a thousand shoes a thousand
times over but like
it just it's still great to just get a
free cool thing that somebody sent you
can i say one cool thing you did sean is
that it wasn't all kds it was like kds
and a couple kyries and some lebrons so
it was fun to open up to be like oh
which shoes did i get yeah that was true
did you ever find your shoes by the way
ben i did uh they were the wrong shoes
someone had just grabbed the wrong back
dude came up to me he goes i think
someone stole my shoes i was like ben i
don't think anyone stole your shoes and
i went and made an announcement i go ben
can i find his shoes if you found them
please give it back and he goes dude
someone totally jacked up i was like but
no one stole your tennis shoes we all
just got like dozens of free ones
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
some other great moments so we um
we had gotten connected with the guys at
duke because we're in north carolina and
we had said hey can we come like get a
tour of the place
and they they did so basically some of
the former players who are now coaches
uh some of the current players basically
came together and they um
they took us on a tour of the practice
facility what did you think of that by
the way you're not like uh like it was
it was
obviously cool dude it was so cool it
was so awesome so i don't know anything
about basketball i even made a joke when
we walked in i go ben who's that dude
and it was coach k
uh i was like yeah so like i i don't
really know anything about basketball
but it was inspirational because the
coaches uh
it's like the assistant coaches now i
think they are they told stories about
working with coach k who's like known
for you know 30 years of excellence and
tradition and like uh perfection and he
told they told some amazing stories and
it felt i did feel like i was in a
um i don't know holy place when i was
there so i want to say uh something
about that too so
one of the players there um emile
jefferson who he he was uh on the
championship team uh maybe somebody
was like the coach like the guy leading
the tour
yeah he was the guy kind of telling the
most stories and i just want to give him
a shout out because
basically they didn't know what the hell
was going on neither did our group all
of a sudden 30 people are standing face
to face in this practice facility it's
like so uh
okay who are you guys and uh like what
am i supposed to show you what what are
we doing here and like dude he totally
weighed it he did good it also helped
that we had mr beast here and uh hussain
so everyone thought that like oh
everyone else here must be famous too i
just don't recognize him yeah yeah
exactly it's like um they didn't know
we're all just prolific newsletter
creators yeah
podcasters and newsletter creators and a
couple actually famous people yeah they
ball we blog
exactly
so he tells the story and i just got to
give him credit like
uh he was
it's really hard to like that was like a
make or break moment do you have a story
or do you not and i just want to
encourage everybody to like have a story
in your back pocket like whatever the
most common question you get which is
like in this case what's coach k like
you know what was it like playing here
what's it like you know whatever
and don't just be like it was good man
really cool really special to be here
yes i mean it's just been awesome i've
learned so much it's like that's what i
would say nine out of ten people would
have done he's like you know when i
first got here i thought it was hot [__]
blah blah blah and then coach k was just
yelling at me yelling at me man i was
just i didn't know what to do he was
like later on i realized that once he
stopped chilling at you that's when it's
bad because then he's giving up on you
but like you know for that moment he's
like in some practices and then you say
he said a counterintuitive thing he's
like some practice he just sat there man
he didn't say anything
the whole practice he wouldn't say a
word and you just think oh man he's just
checked out like he's not doing anything
like i don't know it's weird i guess he
doesn't care right now but then three
weeks later he would reference something
that he was observing that day
and you're like dude you've been
watching everything you've got like
cameras in the walls and microphones
like how do you know all this stuff he
tells the story he's like you know we
have this one little film room and the
secret like he's like see that wall
right there there's like a secret door
you go in there there's a there's a film
room right next to the practice gym he's
like and he took me in there he said
come here and i go in there and i
haven't been playing that well and he
takes me in and there's like all these
screens in there he's like and on all of
the screens it's just a picture of me
like various pictures of me all doing
the same pose where i'm just sitting
there like this
i'm like i'm exasperated i'm like mad at
the ref or my teammates or the coach and
your hands are out my hands are out my
hands are up my palms are up i'm like
it's like the the y like type of like
expression
and already everybody's on the edge of
their seat the story yeah they're like
hey this is cool this is interesting i
want to know what was this about he's
like he said look look at this son
you're one of the leaders of this team
you look like a beggar
you're sitting there with your palms out
begging for a call from the referee
begging for the coaches to help you
begging for your teammates to do
something he's like you're a leader i
don't ever want to see you look like a
beggar again he's like don't don't do
that this is not the body language of a
leader my face look at your face look at
your hands and
and i was like such a good story such a
good story he's like for the rest of
he's like dude rest of the season you'll
watch me if something happens i'm like
this he's like you know it does a
totally different pose he's like you'll
never catch me doing that pose again and
i thought a great way to connect with
the group right like we're all like kind
of ceo leader type so you tell a
leadership story you tell a
counter-intuitive one an entertaining
one and it's a happy ending right i just
thought man he just killed it with that
moment and i just felt
for myself if i look at how i was
hosting that weekend i felt like if i
was gonna level up how these things go
that's one thing i want to work on is
in those moments where you need to
either make the toast welcome everybody
in tell the story get people primed for
what we're about to do
like the difference in the whole
experience can just be in that like
two minute story right before you start
and that's what i want to get great at
dude let me tell you uh what i another
thing that was great about this event
and it involved it's all about you and
again when i say you and sean i'm
actually meaning probably 40 sean 60 ben
levy
so basically
you
i told you this like three times you
pulled this off perfectly and you nailed
the important stuff
and you failed and ignored the
non-important stuff the non-important
stuff is the nice to haves that but
here's the thing most people would spend
time on that so you had no website
you had no like invitation you just dm
people you said venmo me money and i
didn't know what i was getting into but
i just trusted you
you
last minute sent us the address so
basically like on the way to the airport
you told me the address of where i had
to go to i didn't know what time dinner
was i just know i just sometime
throughout the day hopefully i show up
at this dress and i and i and like
hopefully there's a place to sleep all i
did was i sent you money and i told you
my shoe size that's all i did and i
showed up and there was all these
amazing people there and you nailed it
and you did it quickly and the airbnb
was perfect we had a chef there that was
perfect the house pretty messy kind of
just not not messy horribly but almost
but borderline like this is disgusting
um
we go and play basketball all day and
you have this amazing trainer at this
awesome high school gym that was also
perfect but i'm like all right is there
any like drinks here like what do we
what do we do it's like well there's
just a water fountain and some clif bars
and i was like okay that's less than
ideal but you know what that that
doesn't matter because i i appreciate
that you just like you just order this
[__] on amazon you go but that's not the
important [__] we're gonna focus on the
important stuff you had um we had a
podcast studio there that was already
set up an important thing that we needed
and it was like kind of like a little
hoodie a little hood rat set up and it
was [__] perfect it was exactly what
we needed what like
the people that you selected were
awesome we didn't do any like real
introductions we just hung out and you
just you did i think if you're executing
on a project what you did this weekend
was a perfect example of just getting
the main things right now in the future
maybe you'll know or maybe you'll want
to like all right you know we should
actually have like people didn't like
eat this type of food we should not do
that this time and like that's the
unimportant stuff though and it was
perfect i don't even remember what we
ate i think it was just like hot dogs
and chicken and salmon like nothing
fancy but that wasn't the important part
the important part that we all just sat
around in the kitchen and just told
stories
yeah the um
uh
the
i i really want to do more of these in
the future
because a was just like a dope life
experience and b it kind of merged a
bunch of things into one it's like uh if
i ever need a vacation
but i also want to like hang out with
cool people do networking or go to a
conference but also i want to like do
other stuff besides business with my
life and so with this it was like
got a vacation
got to hang out with a bunch of people
some i knew and some i didn't know half
i knew half i didn't know and the third
was do something fun like oh wow i got
to train with an nba trainer and like
play pick up basketball like that was
just like that was a blast we got to
play inside cameron indoor stadium at
duke uh like there was just like a whole
bunch of dope things that were that were
happening with that and you have to tell
the story so basically we're at cameron
indoor we're at this like you know holy
ground and i don't know how it happened
but basically
uh mr beast he actually did this twice
uh he goes i'll give you a hundred
thousand dollars if you can make this
half court shot right now and this was
the day prior and i think you missed it
but then the second time at duke he goes
first one that makes sense i said it to
him i said it to him so i go
i go jimmy how about a i go jimmy how
about this
um because i know he's once i once i got
to know him a little bit i was like oh
he's like me he's like a bit of a
degenerate gambler like he loves
to gamble he loves action and um and
he's he's also always trying to ratchet
up
the like intensity and awesomeness of
the situation so it's like if the
situation is here but the level can be
raised i think most people talk
themselves out of that he's immediately
like oh level can be raised raise the
levels raise the levels everybody like
oh like you know it'd be like oh you
guys want to play a board game and
they'd be like let's go like right now
do a tournament with the best board game
and let's do this do this thing oh you
want to play basketball i don't care if
it's 1am let's find a gym we're going to
go play i was talking to him about how i
loved coke zero and he goes let's go
right now and go buy a bunch and we was
like all right cool so we just went to
the store and bought coke zero he's like
i've never had it before i want to see
what this is about i i know i have no
input like it was like oh there's some
cool people here you'll get to know him
you'll enjoy this he goes who's cool i
was like uh like all these people he's
like okay hey come sit over here i want
to talk to you and he would like put
somebody in the hot seat he'd be like
who are you what are you what's your
story and he would listen to them for
five minutes and be like wow all right
awesome hey who else is you come here
come here no no no some serious come sit
in the seat and like i was like wow this
guy will always try to like match up the
intensity again in a great way
so we're at we're at duke and we're just
getting a tour
they just finished like a volleyball
game the hoops weren't even down they
were like raised up to the rafters
and i go jimmy
uh i betcha thousand dollars i can hit a
half course shop before you
he goes nah 10 000.
i was like deal and i was like hey uh to
the duke guys there's like any chance
you can like
set up the court real quick yeah i just
bet mr beast 10 grand i can make the
shot before he does and they're like nah
we're not supposed to but i kind of want
to see this 10 grand all right and again
the world he again the reality was we
weren't even supposed to have gotten in
there in the first place all the hoops
were gone there was another game gonna
like somebody else is coming on the
court soon
and
reality has no bearings on what what he
wants like the world will shift to what
he wants basically and so sure enough
all of a sudden the hoops getting come
down ball appears out of nowhere and
we're doing this thing there's like a
circle around us
and now i'm like oh [__] i gotta hit
this shot
and uh took you like four times
yeah basically two or three two or three
attempts no uh you know come up close
but not quite and also you could feel in
the moment that like okay well if this
takes a while something that was really
dope is about to turn really lame to
watch somebody if you ever watch the
slam dunk performance nine times in a
row yeah like there's a performance here
so i was like i better make the [__]
and uh
sure enough shoot it hit it we get it on
video i win 10 grand and uh did he give
you the money
no he hasn't paid me he i gave him my
he's like you want him bitcoin or he's
like or maybe i'll send 10 000 in
pennies to your house uh you know just
like in a giant pallet
he goes he goes by the way that will
cost me two thousand dollars to ship
because he's done that before yeah
yeah exactly he knows the logistics of
this what did you think of i have a
petty guy
well yeah he does what do you what do
you think of sean's execution did i nail
it
yeah yeah i think you were 100 right uh
nailed execution
um
[Music]
yeah like i said um
just everything about it was perfect
sean do you think it's something like
could you just copy and paste it or does
it need to be different every time in
order to create that feeling of it being
special
um i think you could copy paste 80 of it
and you would change 20. um and so i
think that that would be the plan i i
want to basically so i just bought uh a
domain i'm putting up a website today
mfmcamp.com
and i'm going to put the pictures from
this one i just kind of want to make a
blog of where this was but i'm also
going to put a form on there for people
who want to come to this in the future
because half the people who came to this
i didn't know they had reached out i
don't i don't think the idea i think you
should let people apply but i don't
think you got to keep it just like 20 25
people in like you know unfortunately
really exclusive i'm gonna do two
versions i'm gonna do the exclusive one
which is like basically it's it's
hitters only right no small boy stuff
there um that's what this one was like
right 20 20 25 people in the room
everybody had their claim to fame
whatever it may be right like we had one
guy al who's built the biggest quilt
company in the world they do over 100
million dollars a year selling quilt you
know patches and accessories and stuff
like that and it's like that's his com
that's his he bought a town and he's
making it like the quilting set like the
quilting hub of america like a tourist
destination for quilters everywhere like
the guy's crazy but he's totally
different than the next guy who's done
it in a different area right so
um so i'm gonna do
one or two of these a year
that are the small 20 person type of
events i might even go smaller i might
even go 15. i think this was too many
people and um
then i also want to do one that's like
one not the less the d league
yeah that is it's not the d it's more
like the b the b league right it's like
but these are people who are they get
our culture they listen to the league
isn't it like development league isn't
like the nba like
yeah yeah yeah that's true they changed
the g league now because d sounded bad
but but basically
that i want to do like a thousand person
or 500 or something bigger maybe not
maybe not that big maybe it's 200 but
that'll be like a retreat somewhere it's
less intimate less exclusive but it's
still people who are they're all
entrepreneurs they're all they've all
made their first million right according
to the podcast they all listen to the
pod they get the jokes they get the
humor they get the style so when they
show up they know the vibe the vibe the
vibe should be immaculate from day one
and that's what i that's what i want to
do so that's what i'm thinking of doing
out of this um what do you think of that
idea
yeah i think it's awesome uh i i i told
kip the cmo of hubspot i go kip
uh sean just did this on his own but uh
like you gotta
carve out some budget and just let us
let us or let him have this money and
and we gotta make this happen this is
magical and he's like dude i followed
all your guys's picture and instagram
from this this is amazing we're in
and uh yeah dude i thought it was
awesome i you i think it's a really good
idea you should do a bigger one that
bigger one the bigger one will be
freaking exhausting but uh it'd be fun
yeah totally i hate events but the fact
that i still want to do this even though
i hate events shows me that it's like a
good thing to do um
okay so those were a couple of the
things uh can i share a couple of the
other kind of like
takeaways or anecdotes so um
one takeaway
a lot of people there
like were pretty
i'll call it like straight and arrow now
like it's like a lot of the
conversations were like about their kids
they it wasn't like it wasn't a ton of
alcohol needed for the like dude i don't
think the social media like like you
know socializing nick had like a whiskey
and like maybe other people had like a
beer but there was virtually no alcohol
no drugs
at worst it was like some tobacco and
that was it
and we played board games that was you
that was just that was me no that was
hubert he smoked a cigar austin reef
smokes smoked a cigar yeah
yeah true i'm gonna read this so nick uh
who's sweaty start up on twitter he goes
he wrote a blog post did you read this
thing he goes yeah i spent the weekend
with multi-millionaires here's what i
learned
and he goes we organize this thing blah
blah and he goes he texted uh his wife
after he put a screen shut up he goes
i'm very inspired by a lot of the guys
here had some incredible deep
conversations with some spectacular
people a few things i'm ready to change
right away number one i want a therapist
number two i want to bring energy to the
kids i think i need to disconnect from
the phone to do that number three i want
to drink less alcohol number four i'm
ready to bring a positive mindset to
being a family man and a dad and nurture
that garden in the same way that i've
nurtured business and social
uh number five i want to honor you like
treating you like the queen that you are
so lucky to have you right it's like
whoa like you know those are some you
know come to jesus uh you know sort of
thoughts and i'm glad that you know uh
he had that impression and so he said
something he goes he goes here's my
takeaways he goes we're all dorks he
goes i was expecting a room full of
giants people with charisma blah like
don't get me wrong some people could
tell great stories but for the most part
everyone's just normal
and had like overcome odds they were
just smart storytellers who were really
obsessed with their thing
no number two yeah we played like board
games and we like went swimming like it
was like
children stuff that were already yes
he goes we all suffer with insecurity
fear of failure and a general emptiness
at times because i talked to a few guys
who enjoyed their success more than five
years ago have been worth 20 plus
million for a long time and they spoke
about business as an unhealthy addiction
how it leaves them searching for more an
empty feeling after an exit other others
talked about their nagging ego and need
for more and bigger others discussed a
constant fear that the career uh about
their career that they weren't worthy or
didn't have have what it took and just
general insecurity
another one they had lots of kids a lot
of guys spend a lot of time talking
about their kids and and how they spend
a lot of energy in this area uh most of
the folks spent a lot of time talking
about how they're trying to raise good
kids um
and how they're trying to help their
kids embrace the struggle rather than
protect them from it because very few of
them had had new groundbreaking
businesses most started normal
businesses that already existed not
revolutionary technologies they saw a
need and just went after it better than
anyone else good old-fashioned boring
stuff
um
he talked about the humility is
astounding most of the people
money has not turned these people into
jerks they're still mentally tough uh
still willing to to you know to slum it
they are humble they're searching for
ways to improve blah blah blah
most didn't drink alcohol um
you know a couple of us had one or two
drinks but i'm surprised uh that you
know this many people were able to you
know socialize hang out without using
alcohol it inspired me to do more
um
yeah basically he's like the big
question for most people in the room is
what am i going to do with my life and
um
he goes
he goes one last quote he goes
he goes i talked to somebody who said
this i walk him around my house in my
office sometimes just acting like i'm
doing things then i just go outside walk
around or i cut wood
he's like you know
he's like he's like everybody is kind of
you know on some kind of search so
good recap
to add to that most people were really
transparent
and so like we would be like if we would
ask them money questions like and they
would just say this is what i have this
is where i put it this is what i do and
they would be fairly specific or
um
uh they would say no like i don't have
enough to do this this and this like
we're done about flying private like no
i'm not wealthy enough i can't do that i
can't afford it and i was like oh okay
that's cool uh or i am wealthy enough to
do that and here's how much i spend but
i didn't do it until i hit this number
or
um you know like my wife and i argue
about x y and z or i'm nervous about my
children for these reasons or like
people were really transparent
can i tell you a few more mr beast
nuggets real quick
uh yeah
because i think he was the most uh like
alien of he was the alien amongst aliens
basically um
so he's got a runner did you did you
know this did you see this
you know what i mean
no so
there is somebody 24 hours a day he's
two people they do 12-hour shifts well
there's those two kids that were they
were there
uh no no those were that one guy was
like his social media guy stick to guy
another guy with somebody else so um
uh
by the way they're not they're not kids
they're just a little younger than us
right like they're like they're 20 yeah
yeah yeah yeah not like 10. well he's
he's a kid kind of sorry no disrespect
guys so
dude you're like 31. you're like young
well they just had young energy like
they were like they had like college kid
energy in that they were like this was
their vocation and they just lived in
the dorm and they were at like it's at a
basketball camp they were at like mr
beast video camp yeah for us this was
like a weird getaway from the from adult
life and they're like yeah this is just
like i don't know i guess i just bounced
over here and tomorrow i'll bounce
somewhere else and they like wore like
you know yeezys or something like that
and we're like that's what i mean by
kids these are funky shoes you know son
what dude he got there they had 300
sandals on i was like what are those are
there like uh yeezys i was like what
yeah so that's what i mean they were
they were younger in psychodemographic
yeah i was an idiot i was like oh i was
like whoa those are like super crocs
what are those they're like
easy slides are the hottest shoes
on earth
i was like ah sweet super crocs sport
mode crocs yeah so uh anyway so so he's
got a runner basically he's got a dude
outside the house at all times just
sitting in his car
24 hours a day it's a personal doordash
so if he ever needed something i don't
know if you noticed he was like oh i
want to play settlers of catan so he's
like hey can you go get katan and the
guy would just run to the store go get
katan and bring it back within 50. what
he was outside our house the whole time
and he's outside the studio wherever he
goes
these two people are there 12-hour shift
seats so 24 hours a day
he's got somebody just
watching his back ready to do they track
do they do like five minutes
we went to duke and you know he's
wearing his easy slides and it was like
um
uh we're all of a sudden they were
moving the hoop so we could play so he's
like hey go get my shoes from the car
and like i need my shoes can you go get
them from the car like just like you
think anything like i'm hungry and they
would just go and they would like or
even before you hungry they would just
go they're like hey i think he has like
crohn's disease or something like that
so he's got a very specific diet so they
were like um
like there's just like [__] out of like
yogurt in the fridge at all times i was
like where is all this yogurt coming
from and like his runner was just
stocking the fridge like
need a oh he's gonna forget to eat so
i'm just gonna go hand him this at this
time like that's some real
that's like a really funny and he and so
he's talking about he's like he's like
yeah he's like i don't get he's like all
these people here are wealthy but like
nobody here had that he's like why don't
why don't you guys do that it's like
it's a waste of your time to go do those
things right like if you value your time
why why would you
and i was like i was like he's like why
do you think that is i was like honestly
i don't think any of us had even thought
about it like i was like
i never considered this possibility i
didn't know that was a thing yeah
in the tech industry like the biggest
winners elon like the google guys
zuckerberg like they
you would describe this for a lot of
them and so it's actually like a a trait
commonly found with greatness which is a
very matter of fact
simple way of looking at things that is
unafraid of like how that looks how that
sounds or like what it costs so for
example he reinvests everything into
every video and i was like okay so um
you know
what's the game plan here he's like well
just you know like make the best videos
possible
just put it all in keep growing it make
this the biggest thing ever and like you
know that's my goal and i was like okay
but like you know what about xyz it's
like
i told you my goal so why would i
consider xyz
were you not listening to the first part
so i call it i started to think about
this because again the stunning thing
for me was i had never really met
anybody who puts every hour every dollar
and every ounce of their soul into their
wild ambition that's what i took away
from him um it doesn't matter if he was
a youtuber or an athlete in fact the
trainer there used to train with kobe
and kobe's daughter gigi before they
passed away and i was you know i was
like dude i hate to be the guy who asks
you for a kobe story but like
you got to tell me a kobe bryant story
like what you got
and he started telling me i was like you
know is the work ethic thing legit
because like i don't know if you follow
this but like on reddit there's youtube
no dude yeah i sat and listened to that
guy talk he was he was that was that was
probably the best storytelling so
there's these stories about kobe that
you don't know if they're marketing or
if they're real where it's like
kobe would wake up like there's a story
like dwayne wade who's another you know
hall of fame basketball he's like
yeah i we went to the olympics that's my
first time i got to see how kobe works
because he was a competitor before that
now we're on the same olympic team he's
like we got to the gym at 6 a.m kobe was
already there like fully sweating we're
like
did you what are you doing we just got
here for the 6 a.m practice what are you
doing and he's like oh this is like yeah
i'm right i'll be ready in a minute
they're like well why are you sweating
so much he's like oh i had my first
workout at four i'm just finishing up
i'm gonna join you guys in a sec i'm
gonna go get my ankles re-taped and then
go back and and the guys so he's got
this legendary workout i think so i was
asking the guy i was like is it real
he's like he's like dude i thought it
was [__] too he's like so i started
texting him at four he's like he hit me
back right away the guy was awake he was
at the gym he's like it was insane he's
like he's like and then i was like okay
so he's got the crazy work i think what
else he's like he had this ability where
if you were in the room with him he's
like most of the guys i work with the
famous athletes they're like kind of
like 80d they're like
if they don't know if you're not like a
bullseye of what they're interested in
they don't think that they don't look at
you as someone they can learn something
from always yeah just normal people he's
like so you know they'll check their
phone they'll look around they'll talk
to you they'll talk to their manager
they'll talk to this person they're just
whatever they're all over the place you
said kobe if he got in a room with you
you'd feel like there's only you in the
room he would lock eyes he would not
look at his phone he would not move away
he would ask you questions he would
remember your name and the name thing
was fascinating did you hear that story
yeah
yeah yeah yeah the other guy luke tells
the story so he goes
uh he goes we're at the gym and i think
the first time i've ever met kobe he's
like we're playing pickup and i was
playing with i jumped in he's like a
trainer he's like i jumped in the game
and i missed like six or seven shots
and kobe just doesn't say anything to me
he's like after the game he goes
damn you damn damn man you come make a
shot or what and the guy goes
i'm a volume shooter bro like you should
know
and kobe like i mean they tried to like
kind of basically make fun of copy
copy's like oh only volume i know is
five like five rings he's like um so
they start so that whatever they have
that one interaction takes five seconds
they just laugh move on with life
three weeks later he comes back to the
gym
and um
the guy walks into the gym and kobe goes
what a volume
and just like remembered who he was kate
remembered his nickname and so then the
guy was like already impressed with that
he's like but he's like i had never
talked to him because i never told him
my name nothing he had asked somebody
what my name is so that three weeks
later he goes
he's like i was leaving and kobe goes
damn luke you're not gonna say bye
yeah wait you know my name and secondly
you're stopping i just didn't want to
bother you like and the guy was like
sneaking out like just casually trying
to leave and kobe just saw him walking
around like dude what the hell aren't
you gonna say goodbye to me and so he
knew his name he knew he's like he's
like he's like he remembers everybody's
name and i asked him once i go kobe's
like why do you like is that easy for
you he's like no it's not that easy i
just make an effort he's like why do why
do you care like to learn all these
people's names he goes
because for most people this is the only
time they're ever going to interact with
me and
if i remember their name was something
so simple
and they not only will they remember it
forever they'll tell everybody they know
about this he goes so i'm not just
remembering i'm not just like making an
impression on them i'm making an
impression on a thousand people
throughout their lifetime that they're
gonna tell this kobe bryant story to
and i thought that was so baller and
that was the same the same thing i was
interested about mr beast i admired
about kobe in that same way he did an
even crazier story where alex had
mentioned like a few weeks prior that
his mom's birthday was on a particular
date and on that particular date kobe
texted alex the trainer goes what's your
mom's cell number and he facetimed the
mom goes what's up mom you know what i
just want to say i hope you have a
wonderful birthday today and alex is
like crazy i didn't even facetime my mom
until her happy birthday
yeah exactly so those stories were
amazing again those are the moments in
between the moments right you can't plan
for that but you put a bunch of people
in the room and serendipity like that
can happen
but uh the other story that was like
that so
um
so the trait i think i was calling mr
beast i was like he has a level of
commitment that i call kamikaze
commitment he has a kamikaze level
commitment
to winning kobe had that too that's our
new phrase bro
that's a job the manifest cowboys and
the people who got that kamikaze
commitment the dogs and so
i was like how do you compete with a
youtuber like mr beast i thought about
this i was like
uh cause i was like literally i was like
could i fund somebody could i just give
someone like five million dollars to
become mr beast and i was like
i don't think it would actually work
because
not just the talent there's like he's
not the best looking dude he's not the
funniest guy he's
honestly all the things he knows about
youtube you could learn i i could tell
you everything he you know you need to
know about youtube then 85 percent that
you would need to know to get pretty far
ahead right there's the last 15 that'll
crew over time but like
dude
you need a great clickable title and
thumbnail here's what makes it clickable
the first 10 seconds you need to hook
people and tell them what they're going
to get out of this video and then you
need to visually stimulate them and then
you need to use these cuts and then you
need to introduce a twist in order to
keep their attention and here's the
metric you need to hear about right like
you could train that what you can't
train is the guy is willing to put all
the money he makes back into the next
videos
so like imagine competing in a business
with somebody who's willing to take no
profit
like they're going to beat you on price
they're going to beat you on value
because they're willing to lower their
price that they're willing to reinvest
all of their profits into building a
better product so he's willing to
reinvest all of his money
and all of his time
into this and then that compound so at
first that was really cheap that was you
know the first brand that gave him a ten
thousand dollar the first brand trying
to give him a five thousand dollar
sponsorship i don't know if you know the
story they quit trying to give him five
thousand dollars for the video he was
like he's like i talked to the guy on
the phone for like an hour being like
dude make it ten thousand more people
will click she's like ten thousand just
that number ten grand in the title is
gonna get way more clicks than five i
don't know why it's just five is not the
same as ten in the title and so it's
like just give me ten they're like dude
we just our budget he's like i'm not
even gonna keep the ten i'm gonna give
all ten away so the gate they said yes
to ten he immediately went and gave ten
grand to a homeless guy and then that
video gets like a million views and all
the stuff that pays pays the video off
the advertiser's happy so then they get
20 grand 30 grand 50 grand 100 grand and
eventually advertisers willing to pay
nearly a million dollars for to be a
part of these videos
but he's willing to take that and pour
it all back in so how do you compete
with somebody who's willing to spend all
of your creative energy and time and all
of their money i think that is like
just kind of awe-inspiring to see
somebody execute the like sort of
kamikaze commitment strategy i know i'm
not willing to do it maybe because i'm
willing to do it i got kids i don't know
what it is i don't know what the factors
are it's really that i just
i don't need to
it's like it's like i said before like i
think being olympian being an olympian
is a trap
like i don't need to be a gold medalist
i don't want to be michael phelps and
give up like 20 years of my life to
train every single moment of every
single day to become that like
i don't hate it
i don't think his lifestyle
is fitting for happiness and
maybe
maybe even being fulfilled
but and by the way he would agree like
he said that yeah he said that
and i'm happy that he exists and i know
i am not that
yeah yeah exactly those are the two
certainties that i have on that you know
before before they are real and i and i
and i and i am not it
face tattoos and cornrows right
yeah they said musical rose i'm cool
they other people have them
not for me
yeah
um before i went there i was like maybe
we should really like double down on you
maybe we should triple down on youtube i
was like i think i could become like the
biggest business creator on youtube do i
want that i don't know
and then i when we were there there was
like a 30 minute shoot where he was like
a photo shoot for the thumbnail of one
of his videos
and i was like
yeah i don't think i want to do this
like i don't think in my day these are
the things i want to hold in my
interview i think i think somebody is
willing to do that of course somebody's
willing to do that many people are
willing to do that to win that game and
i was like i'd rather do a game where
i'm willing to pay the price that it
takes to get the outcome that i want no
and try try not to do it you and we we
could play that game but you don't have
to play it his way you know his way is a
reckless way and it works but i don't
think you have to you know like i like
there are there are lots of different
examples of people succeeding in
different ways you know the wealthiest
guy there keep in mind was basically he
was the wealthiest guy there by a lot i
think and he played the game totally
different
than than jimmy did yeah but i think the
youtube game that you know like there is
a
uh
i think there is a default path and
you'd have to really be saying i'm going
to go try to be an outlier right i'm not
going to be on i'm not going to if you
want to be still to be if you want to be
about the top yes if you wanted to be
the top mainstream type of guy i agree
but there's like we wanted a sweet
lifestyle where we're making a few
million dollars a year doing it like
you're right there's many ways to do
that but if you want to get the top
right and that's the question i ask
myself do i want to try to go for that
no i don't but i would i would i'd be
okay with pretty good
and doesn't that feel weird when you
spend time with people who are like they
hear that sentence and they're sort of
repulsed isn't there a part of you
that's sort of like embarrassed to say
i'm okay with just good enough there's a
part of me that's for sure embarrassed
to feel that
yeah and i used to feel so
i used to feel embarrassed about that
and then i realized i started like renal
about stoicism and i got went into this
ryan holiday like
deep rabbit hole and i'm like oh yeah
we're all going to die and we're all
going to be [__] and like just ashes
like what i'm not going to play other
people's games but here's the thing i
want to wrap up with as i left
that weekend
a little angry at myself because i've
experienced envy pretty hardcore and i
experienced like inadequacy of like you
know a lot of places where i go i'm the
big shot there we were the low we were
probably below average in terms of
traditional success and i remember being
there and i'm like
i am nothing and i should want more and
i should achieve more and i remember
feeling that way and i felt guilty that
i felt that way i was like why why am i
like you know i why am i feeling envy
this is envy's like the one of the worst
uh
feelings you should you can have envy's
in some regards worse than hate uh and
so like i remember feeling envy and i
was like [__]
i i'm falling down the traps i'm falling
i'm doing it i'm doing what everyone
says you do and we all know you're not
supposed to do and i said forever i
wouldn't feel that way i made the number
that i made and i thought i won't want
any more after that and i'm wanting more
and i'm i'm giving into it and i felt
really guilty about that
i know exactly what you mean um
i'll tell you what worked for me
to like it's like a it's like a hunger
pang right you can't prevent yourself
from feeling hungry but you can choose
how you're gonna satisfy that right how
you're going to address it
and uh i told i'd come on the pod before
when i had visited that person's house
that like they had like a 20 million
dollar house and i was like wow this is
just incredible and
and i wasted the first two days
just kind of like being envious and or
like bullshitting about why this like
yeah but you know i
i want to focus on family you know
coming up with these like other things
i'm like yeah
this is this is actually bad for these
reasons yeah just cognitive dissonance
yeah just like trying to convince myself
that i was good and and so you know and
and what i'd come away with there was
like actually the right way to handle
that moment is to just reframe it like
oh this is sick i'm getting to sample a
set of options to see which one i want
oh okay you have this and you live this
lifestyle tell me about that i want to
hear about that i want to just this is
just the person walking around at the
party with the tray
oh yeah i'll try the bruschetta
okay do i like bruschetta is that what i
want okay now let me try the shrimp okay
is that what i want is that what i like
so that's how i that's at this place i
didn't feel the envy per se because as
soon as it came up i was like
oh this is cool i'm getting this guy
lives in puerto rico and does this and
this instead of feeling jealous i pay so
much in taxes and he doesn't let me
learn about that this person has this
wild success and they kind of work this
one one week out of a month
all right is that what i want what's
that like you know tell me about that
you know like i was getting the sample
which just helps me figure out what i
really want and i get more broad
exposure and at the end of the day
you're you're you're the one that
brought them all together though so uh
like but i definitely know what you mean
dude when it was like all right let's go
around the circle and like tell
what's your story what's your what's
your thing i'm like oh damn my little
like you know cricket level of success
compared to the whales you know like
there is a moment where you panic i've
always had this in any group setting
where they're like say your name and you
know an interesting thing about you it's
like you know for a my initial reaction
is like there's nothing interesting
about me not one iota of me is
interesting i should just leave the room
how far away is the fire alarm what
happens if i vomit do i have to do this
like you know like there's that that
happens in three seconds and then my
body's like oh wait what do you do what
are you talking about like and then i
come back to normal but i yeah that
reaction happens to be in these group
settings for sure
that was uh i i remember i felt the
exact same way and i was like i am
nothing
so
but
here it kind of made me feel better when
people who i didn't know
told me about my life and i'm like ah
[__] you listen got you like you know
what i mean so
i gotta tell you that
a little better a totally unrelated
story but do you just remind me of it
it's so hilarious once upon a back in
the day me and my buddies used to go
gamble a lot we didn't have much money
we were just fresh out of college we
basically had won a business plan
competition and we were like extending
the runway by going and playing poker
and like trying to like win a few extra
thousand dollars doing it but sometimes
we would lose and so who knows we
probably knew it out you know slightly
down
anyways
one of the guys
he
would play table games where you have no
edge you're you're going to lose and so
he'd go play craps whatever and when he
would lose we'd be like all right man
like we should cut it off and he's like
hold on let me just go get a coffee to
go to the atm and get more money and
come back and we're like ah dude he's a
degenerate we got to stop him but we
didn't so we came back up to the hotel
room
and he's gone for like another five
hours five a.m he comes back into the
room and i wake up because i hear the
noise
and he doesn't know that i'm awake we're
we're asleep he doesn't know that i'm
awake and he's he comes up to the he
stands in front of the mirror in the
hotel room
all right actually first he goes to the
bathroom changes into the robe which is
always the sign of somebody trying to
get their value out of the hotel room
because they lost a bunch of money in
the casino a little tip for degenerates
so when they start using all the
shampoos and stuff they're trying to get
back at the casino so he goes comes out
in a robe he's looking at the mirror and
he just goes
you suck
he just goes you fat [__] you
just dissing something he just goes and
he just holds up his head he goes five
five iphones
you lost five
iphones telling you
dude i started laughing so hard he
realizes that we're awake and then it
was like it totally lightened the mood
just because of how funny the situation
was
five iphone we always like if i go
gambling say how many iphones i'm like
three iphones i lost three i lost three
phones rappers use like racks like how
many racks did you lose or how much
racks do you win we use iphones and uh
dude i'll never forget that story it was
so funny
that's that's what i was telling myself
uh uh
a million subscribers you only have a
million subscribers
i remember um
delete your account
that weekend you and i
this channel we hit 100 000 subscriber
subscribers and then i went and looked
at jimmy's numbers and i think he was
adding a million a week or sorry a
million a month i forget what it was but
uh or sorry a hundred thousand a day he
was what he was adding and i was like
yeah we were like we just hit a hundred
thousand he goes nice today
i remember that's how i was like oh we
suck we suck so hard uh i felt that way
uh ben are people is this going to be a
great episode i i i got so much energy
from this this is definitely
self-indulgent but like who cares i
needed to debrief this
and i would say like
in some parts we're patting ourselves at
backstab parts we're making fun of us
ourselves sometimes making fun of other
people i hope we weren't hard on anybody
uh you know ben what do you think
um it's good the one thing we didn't
talk about was the actual basketball
which i just you know oh
yeah so here's the breeze of bed's
saying that so in terms of best
basketball player what a coincidence ben
it was like ben was number one and then
nick huber was like probably number two
number three commodore was two or number
three but ben was clearly the best and
at one point ben i think a couple times
he dunked in the game but at one point
he like dunked on jimmy and there's a
perfect picture ben was without a doubt
the best basketball player there that
that that was that was for sure
so i have to tell you uh before going
i was talking to my wife and i was like
you know i think a big i think i'm gonna
be the best person there but like a big
struggle for me is i want to like keep
everything in check like
you know there's a lot of people there
with a lot of money a lot of influence
like a lot of a big audience like they
could do things for me in the future i
don't want to like offend anyone or
upset anymore like keep giving check
like i don't want to embarrass anybody
or like be too confused yeah like
or just like seem like a ball hog or
like come off the wrong way right uh i
like i just wanna make sure everyone has
a good time everyone has fun so i go and
literally and for like five minutes i'm
good for like five minutes i'm just
playing in the flow of the game make
sure everyone has a good time and then
nick huber comes down and like does a
little move on me and scores sean
i don't know if you did this on purpose
sean comes over and is like
dang nick huber's good i think he's the
best one here
and i lose it i lost it i like
immediately went out of my mind i was
like you think he's the best one here
i'll tell you exactly what you say
because we're in the middle of a game by
the way but this is not like i didn't
like i don't even know how we were
having such a conversation but i was
like i said something i was like damn i
was like nick's good i was like this one
we got a guard nick i think he's the
best one here
and um because we don't know anybody
here right we don't know who's who plays
who doesn't play like we're all finding
out in the first five minutes like who
knows how to ball who doesn't and um
and ben goes
f that
he goes f that i'm guarding him i know
you want to go you got f that i'm the
best player here i'm guarding him and
and then you and then you proceeded to
so then that whatever you think he said
i'm shutting him down yeah you go i'm
shutting him down and uh and so you
whatever you you go we score we ended up
winning that game
and uh and then like whatever i stubbed
out whatever and so
five minutes later nick subs out of the
game and he's just walking away
muttering to himself he just goes
i can't even score on ben he's like a
wall
and i was like wow mission accomplished
like you really flipped that switch and
it was so fun to see it because honestly
every every moment i've interacted with
you outside of that game or like pick up
basketball
you are if i would just describe you as
too nice
you are you know like you are overly
nice you are overleague
you're a very polite guy you are low ego
very very humble too humble i want you
to have more of an edge and an ego and
want to make your podcast the biggest
podcast in the world and like
i never saw that until we were playing
basketball i saw a different side of you
dude i was talking i was talking [__] to
him just to get him fired up and he like
just was he did the same thing to me
where he just was like he just had his
way with me and but i was talking [__]
to him constantly just to get him going
and he totally got going and uh sean
you're really good too you you in that
last game you had a bunch of threes uh
you were shooting good
yeah yeah we haven't talked about
shawn's big moment
uh what was the big moment the halfway
shot
no the the big moment was when we were
in the championship game and uh i think
my back was failing a little bit we were
on the same team yeah what was going on
you were looking like you were in pain i
didn't understand that i was like okay
give me the ball
so you guys know that like big dunk i
had uh early on i threw my back out when
i did that dunk so for the whole rest of
the day i had like no lift and i was in
like pretty severe pain
and uh
and um
so we're gonna lose like we're gonna
lose pretty bad and then sean
how many points did you have you hit
like four threes in a row in like a
couple twos you like took over the game
yeah i was also lucky that i was fresh i
went and dropped husband off at the
airport so i came back in like right for
the playoffs basically everybody's been
playing for like you know an hour before
that and i got to come in completely
fresh so that was kind of lucky um and
then sam we um
we don't have a moment where you dunked
or took over the game but i do have an
award for you we me and ben uh ben levy
we started creating some awards for
people and i'll just give you a sneak
preview your award is
person who most played basketball like
it was football
i didn't know the rules physical mother
effort man you like
dude if i was guarding you you're the
only person that anybody else there okay
they could score on me whatever i'm
never gonna call for a switch i'm gonna
be like i got this guy if i was guarding
sam i'd be like uh who wants to switch
i'm not looking to be like a battering
ram right now uh
nobody else started boxing out earlier
than you
well i go to bed and comment i go hey
guys i don't really know the rules i
can't dribble i can't really do anything
what would you like me to do like well
you got a big ass and you could jump
high so just like
uh stay down low and just jump up and
grab the ball and give it to me i go yes
sir i i got you i got you captain and so
that's all i did it was amazing
uh it was a lot of fun and uh yeah let's
do it again all right that's the up
[Music]
you